- Okay, I'm Steve Anderson.
I was previously the Chair
of the Linguistics Department
at Yale, which will
turn out to be relevant.
It's my pleasure to introduce Gerald Shea.
Gerry is not either a
linguist or a psychologist
and so perhaps it's useful for me
to give a little background.
In fact, almost exactly eight years ago
I received in the mail a manuscript
from someone I didn't know about a topic
about which I didn't know very much.
I'm sure Bob Frank as
current chair will confirm
the fact that we get lots of...
The Chair of Linguistics
at Yale gets lots of things
and some of them are a little unusual.
But this one seemed to be
worth a lot more attention
and not only because the
author was a Yalie, BA 64.
The manuscript I had, which
was called Language of Light.
No, it was called a Song Without Words.
It was interesting for two
somewhat different reasons.
On the one hand it
described the experience
of someone whose language
experience is rather different
from any of the ones
that cognitive scientists
tend to study.
On the one hand we study hearing people
who learn spoken languages
and on the other hand
we study Deaf people
who learn sign languages
but here was the experience of someone
who had lost a great deal of his hearing
at a very early age, but that
fact hadn't actually been
properly diagnosed
until much later in life
and he succeeded in the hearing community
despite his hearing deficit.
Getting through Yale
and getting through Columbia Law School.
This seemed to me was a
situation that cognitive science
ought to pay attention to.
It's rather unusual to characterize
the linguistic experience
of someone functioning
in a spoken language who has
actually very limited access
to speech as a consequence
of the hearing deficit.
So on the one hand that struck
me as an interesting problem
for cognitive scientists.
On the other hand the book
contained a great deal
of really interesting information
about the history of the
emergence and development
of signed language in
France, which as we know
is the background out of which ASL comes,
work that was based on
Gerry's work in the libraries
and archives in France in
which taught me a great deal.
I mean I had done some
reading on this background
but I learned a lot from
looking at this manuscript.
So I was happy to encourage it
and to recommend it for publication
and to provide some comments,
especially on the linguistic aspects.
As I've said, Gerry isn't a linguist
and there were some things that I thought
needed a little bit of commentary.
But then in 2013, the book was published
as Song Without Words.
The book is lovely and an eloquent book.
If you haven't read it, you surely should.
But when I saw what came out in print
I was somewhat less happy at
the fact that all this stuff
about the science of sign and
the history had been omitted
and this was almost entirely
about Gerry's experience
as a partially hearing person.
Well, I talked to him
about this and he said
that's because the
publishers wanted this to be
a general audience book
and they said take all that
science and history stuff out of it.
People will like it more if
it's just a lovely experience.
It is a wonderful book,
but I'm afraid that because
that material was omitted,
it's attracted less attention
from linguists and cognitive scientists
than perhaps it ought to have.
But anyway, I was very
happy a few years later
when I heard from Gerry
that he was interested
in taking the material from
his original manuscript
that hadn't been included, expanding it,
and publishing that as a separate book.
So I was happy to put
him in touch with people
at Yale University Press.
The result is an absolutely wonderful book
on the historical origins and development
of signed languages and the
Deaf community in France
and subsequently in this country.
If you haven't read Language of Light
then you should certainly
read that one too.
So without further ado,
I will turn this over
to Gerry who will, I gather,
be giving you material
mostly from the second book.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you very much, Steve,
and thank you all for coming.
I think I'll take this device off.
Thanks to Raffaella
Zanuttini and her staff
for organizing this conference so ably
and it's really a delight to be here
as it was to hear the two prior speakers.
I learned a lot in the first
hour and a half of today.
As Steve explained, I
first became familiar
with the history and languages of the Deaf
when I was looking for information
about the partially Deaf
for my first book, the
memoir that Steve mentioned.
As I discuss at length in that
book, I am partially Deaf,
a condition that arose following
an extended childhood illness.
When others speak, I
hear an elusive language
to which in a rapid course of conversation
I endeavored to give meaning.
The words of this language,
what I call its lyricals,
a term of my invention
are transitional words,
wrong words, non-words.
That in lieu of those actually spoken
register in the minds
of the partially Deaf.
The high frequency and the soft consonants
are usually missing.
The vowels and the occasional
consonant aren't enough.
In my life and the lives of
the partially Deaf like me
are a constant unscrambling of language
punctuated by masks of understanding.
I communicate fairly
effectively using the hearing
I've retained, lip reading, hearing aids,
and an assortment of
assistive listening devices.
There's no time here
to dwell on my history.
It's all in Song Without
Words if you want to buy it
on Amazon and it's all in there.
When I finally did get
hearing aids at age 34,
a lot of sounds came back to me that were
the sounds of childhood.
Crickets, birds, not seagulls
which I've always heard
but, you know, birds twerping in the air.
Piccolos, high stringed
instruments that brought
the melody back to
music for me rather than
the counter point of low instruments.
As to water, water is a beautiful sound.
When I was presenting the
book at a gathering in London,
the first book, a Song Without Words,
a reporter Hayley Campbell
from the New Statesman
came up to me and said
hey, tell me something
that I haven't...
You know, that's not the
critics don't talk about it,
that nobody knows about it.
And I said, well, I'll tell
you a little bit about water.
When I got hearing aids,
the first day I got them
I went off to pee and I had them on
and it was the first time
I realized since childhood
but I had forgotten
that, that when you pee
it actually makes a sound.
So Hayley Campbell in the New
Statesman, she liked that.
And the New Statesman,
these aren't my words,
of course they're hers, she
said imagine what it would be
like going through life without knowing
what piss sounded like.
(audience laughing)
This room scares me to death.
One more anecdote.
I think I was in this room
the very first lecture
I was at Yale and the
teacher started to speak,
I don't know, it was probably history.
Something easy.
When he started to speak,
everybody picked up
their pen and pencil, and
of course, I could hear
his voice and a few words,
but they were actually
starting to write and
I thought, this must be
a very good university since the students
are still writing.
So my theme song might've
been something like
Gaudeamus Igitur since we
can't even hear the teachers.
Moving on to the history now.
I have no fluent understanding
of the signed languages
of the profoundly Deaf, but the grace
and visual clarity of
those who communicate
in sign languages as you have just seen
and as you are seeing
now, are to me, a wonder.
I feel a close affinity to them.
Theirs is not an unplanned,
but a natural visual poetry
at once both the speech
and the music of the Deaf.
Though I live in the realm of the hearing,
a part of my life in the form of my search
for communicative grace
and clarity is quartered
in my understanding of
the world of the Deaf
and I feel as if a part of it.
As I've mentioned, I
originally became familiar
with the history and languages of the Deaf
when I was looking for
information about people like me.
I found that history
so rich and intriguing
and fraught with pathos that
I decided to write about it.
The Language of Light, my
book covers a long history
from the classical period
through our own day
in about 200 pages.
I can't talk about all
of that in half an hour,
thus I'd like to focus on what I consider
the centerpiece of the history of the Deaf
and signed languages,
I.E. the accomplishments
of the great French teachers
of the early 19th century,
notably Auguste Bébian.
This is also the heart of the book.
I call this period the
Enlightenment, or the Age of Bébian.
But I'll also mention in
unforgivable nutshell form
the time before and the
time after that era.
The Age of Bébian as we
shall see was an island
of eloquence and wisdom in a
wide, rapidly running river
of ignorance and prejudice
on the part of the hearing.
A brief note first on what
history and linguistics
have taught us about signed languages
and we've heard much of that this morning.
Children born profoundly Deaf, of course,
hear virtually nothing at all.
They're unable to speak
because their ears can't
transmit to the brain
the information it needs
to shape the imitative
speaking patterns of the voice.
These children then turn
instinctively to gestures
in order to communicate with others.
They do so extraordinarily
and efficiently.
Once they are exposed to a signed language
which they learn quickly and naturally.
They're very soon able exactly like
their hearing counterparts
to express a limitless number
of ideas in well-formed sentences
with impeccable syntax.
The discourse of the Deaf
is not as in the case
of spoken languages
configured by the tongue
and other organs of
speech, arranging molecules
in the air for the ear,
but by the motion of hands
and other gestures that
are transmitted by light
to the eyes of their interlocutors,
hence my title the Language of Light.
Signed languages are just as sophisticated
as our spoken tongue.
They have their own linguistics unit
just as our oral languages do.
When Deaf individuals
render or interpret signs
they use the same regions of the brain
that the hearing do when they speak
and listen to speech.
They are hearing their language.
There is little historical
record of the Deaf
or their languages
before the 16th century,
but signed languages in
various forms and degrees
of sophistication have probably existed
for at the very least, 100,000 years.
For as long as mankind
and thus have Deaf people.
Signed languages were
not invented by anyone,
nor was French, English, or German.
So the time before Bébian.
Aristotle found the Blind
more intelligent than the Deaf
because the Blind could hear.
He believed that all rational discourse
had to be audible.
Sandy Gusten thought Deaf people
could never learn to read.
The Justinian Code in 522
provide that if a person
was Deaf from birth and couldn't speak
he had virtually no rights.
Diderot thought that to teach the Deaf
abstractions was an insurmountable task.
Juan Pablo Bonet in 17th century Spain
called the congenitally
Deaf monsters of nature
and human only in form.
His goal was to cure them by teaching them
how to speak.
He failed, of course, as
did all of his Spanish,
British, Dutch, French, German,
and American Oralist successors.
It was virtually impossible for
a person to speak distinctly
if since birth or early
infancy he or she had not
been able to hear.
Lip reading is just as difficult.
While I and other partially Deaf people
lip read bit, you have to be able to hear
in order to do it well,
or as well as we do
which is not very well.
So forget about all those Deaf characters
reading lips for the CIA
in those movies you see
through hermetically sealed
windows in a telescope.
They're just reciting a
script that they've memorized.
I did though manage to do it once.
I was watching Bill Clinton play golf
with Greg Norman I think,
who wore that, you know,
straw hat and it was the party afterwards
somewhere in the states and
Clinton stepped backwards
and fell over the porch and broke his leg.
They wheeled him out to Air Force One
to set the leg in Washington.
The leg was sticking out and
it was two kilometers out
on the tarmac but the
cameras with their big lenses
were there watching him, but no sound.
Clinton said.
(audience laughing)
Now, the first three
words are clear, right?
What the F are the first three words.
But what's the rest?
What is.
Now, no one in this room has an idea.
Sometimes with context you can get it
and what he said was what the F
are those photographers doing there?
I was very proud of myself
but it was a once in a lifetime event.
(audience laughing)
So what did Bonet think
about Sign Language?
He said if you placed two Deaf mutes
in each other's presence,
meeting for the first time,
they can communicate because
they use the same signs.
(speaking in foreign language)
But he, like others, was
not interested in trying
to understand these
signs, or to ask himself
what the Deaf were saying to each other,
or where their signs came from,
or whether these
communications might be a form
of language, indeed, because it interfered
with their learning the
speech they weren't learning.
He found it important as
alas, many speech therapists
and doctors do today,
quote never to let the
mute use it unquote.
Tortuous so called medical
treatments went hand-in-hand
with the tyranny of oral teaching
in the centuries before the Enlightenment.
These amounted to trials by
ordeal, yielding considerable
suffering, illness, and
sometimes the death.
The premise was that
drilling, cutting, fracturing,
scorching, or poisoning
would open up the ear
and the brain to sounds.
It was into this oral world that arrived
the Abbé de L'Épée, a hearing priest
about to make history.
Observing Deaf twin girls
signing to each other
in 1755, he suspected that their signs
were mutually recognizable
representations of ideas.
Going a step further, he wondered whether
just as hearing children
are taught to write
what they hear, so these
children might be taught
to write what they see, I.E. to be taught
in their own signs the
meaning of written words
and to learn how to read
and write those words.
L'Épée established a school
for the Deaf in Paris
in 1755 and the royal government
ultimately granted him
a substantial annual stipend to run it.
But for all his perceptiveness,
it was the first time
anybody had done this.
L'Épée didn't become fluent in signs
and never understood it
was a complete language.
He gave the students his
own supplementary signs
rather than learning
from them and mastering
their own integral tongue.
He died in 1789 but in 1794,
the government gave his school
its imposing home on the rue Saint-Jacques
where it is today.
The National Institute for Deaf Children,
called Saint-Jacques.
It was to become and
today remains the beacon
of the age of the Enlightenment.
August Bébian who was hearing, and perhaps
history's greatest teacher of the Deaf
was born the year L'Épée died.
He was sent by his father from Guadeloupe
where he was born to study at
the (speaking in foreign
language) in Paris.
His parents were friends of
the director of Saint-Jacques
who offered to find a
place for him to live.
Bébian lived near the
school and in the afternoons
and during the vacations
he was constantly here
joining the Deaf students
in their classes,
workshops, and games.
Although hearing, he
made friends with several
of the Deaf students and
thanks to Jean Massieu,
a noted Deaf teacher
there, learned to sign
as well as those who were Deaf from birth.
An unprecedented accomplishment.
Bébian's writings and
teachings were to become
the cornerstone of the
education of the Deaf
in Europe and of the Deaf
in the United States.
What was needed, he
realized, in order to teach
his students to read and write was
the immediate translation of
their own thoughts and images
as expressed in their own language
into the corresponding
written words in French.
Central to his thought in
teaching is the reality
that words are about the
expression of pre-existing ideas.
An idea, whether the
conception of a material object
or an abstract thought
necessarily precedes
the spoken word interpreted.
It is thus the idea, he
wrote, that must give the word
meaning before the word can,
in turn, become an effective
interpreter of the
idea, or what John Locke
had interestingly called
the sign of the idea.
The hearing ordinarily convey
their thoughts by speaking,
or by writing down words made of letters
that are depictions of the sound we make
with our voices.
What Bébian eloquently called
the painting of our speech.
While students arriving at
Saint-Jacques would have
at least the rudiments of sign,
Bébian in his practical teaching manual
hypothesized the case of a
new student at Saint-Jacques
in order to illustrate
for parents and teachers
that even the teaching of individual words
should begin with the
thought, not the written word.
The teacher might show the
picture of a saber in a book
and then move his dominant
hand from opposite waist
to shoulder height as if drawing a saber
from its sheath.
Exaggerating the sign,
remember they're not recognizable iconic.
The student would invariably do the same.
Bébian would unsheathe
the imaginary saber again
and have the student show
him its picture in the book.
Whereupon he would point
to the written word
beneath the picture.
He would then have the
student finger spell the word
if he knew finger spelling
and ask him in sign
what the word meant, what.
The student would then repeat the gesture
and before long would understand
that this written word
and others were a kind
of conventional drawing
of the idea first expressed in sign.
As to ideas expressed in whole sentences,
Bébian knew that the apparent
goal before his time,
a barren goal before
his time, and continuing
to his own day was to give
to the Deaf and I quote
the mechanical faculty of speech
without enabling them
to attach a precise idea
to its components,
leaving them in the dark
not only as to the absolute value of words
but their relative value
and the influence they have
over each other in the
composition of a phrase.
Hence the drill even today of parents
and speech therapists hammering home
the pronunciation and lip
reading of multiple words
by Deaf children have a
necessity got things backwards.
For without Sign Language, it is difficult
if not impossible to
convey ideas and syntax
and whole meanings of sentences.
Bébian thus correctly
emphasized that French grammar,
which he described as the
relationship between words
and our spoken languages had to be taught
through the median of Sign Language.
He said the Deaf student must
be able to write the word
in order to read it and
to be able to read it
he has to understand it and
he'll be able to understand it
only if he understands the whole sentence.
To do that, his instruction
must begin in sign.
Writing for the Deaf
pre-aphasia represented
nothing at all.
It consists of lines or strokes
forming meaningless characters.
More complex than their painting of sounds
for the hearing, and far more removed
from the underlying
idea that its expression
in their native language
and in trying to read lips
the Deaf are not receiving any idea
but are forced to observe
obscure lip movements
in order to guess sounds they cannot hear
so that they may infer the other sounds
that the lips failed to show at all.
The mental torture of Bonet
and his Oralist successors.
If the Deaf student,
Bébian wrote, is brought to
a standstill to begin with
by the singular difficulty
of pronouncing sounds of which the signs
fixed on paper lie
stationary before his eyes,
how is he going to
understand the rapid signs
that slip through the lips?
It is with their own
language that the education
of the Deaf must begin,
not with the spoken word.
We know, Bébian wrote, that
the Deaf have a language
one doesn't teach them.
Although with art and
exercise, one can offer it
the happiest development.
It is, in a way, the
reflection of their sensations,
the relief of their oppressions.
We carry the same timeless
and limitless principle
within all of us that
of the first language
of any human being which
gives immediate expression
to his thought and is not a translation
of any other language but expresses
his intimate connection with ideas.
One ever looks to his first language
with difficulty for the
expression of an idea.
The thought born in the brain bursts forth
like a flame sparkling in crystal.
How effective was Bébian?
In 1789 at the time of L'Épée's death
there were six schools
for the Deaf in France.
By 1858, there were 54 such schools
and sign was the language of
instruction in all of them.
A significant number of
teachers for the Deaf
were Deaf themselves.
Deaf education and literacy
were springing up everywhere.
With Deaf children in Europe reading
(speaking in foreign language)
as well as Augustine's
Spiritual Dimensions.
Proclaiming that the Deaf
would never be able to read
the very book they were
reading or any other.
On the more practical side,
the potential of the Deaf
in the arts and sciences and
commerce were now realizable
and signed languages
were becoming the motor
of their equality.
Together, Bébian and his
Deaf colleagues and students
were changing the world.
Students were entering the
professions of the hearing,
including work in lawyer offices, banks,
trading companies, et cetera.
Some were accomplished painters and poets.
It wasn't a perfect world but
now they had two languages,
French Sign Language and the written
and European Sign Language.
Languages, pardon me.
The written language of the hearing.
They were succeeding in the hearing world.
What happened in America?
Well, we were, of course,
seeking solutions too
and in 1816, as most of us here know,
Thomas Gallaudet of
Hartford came to France
looking for one, a solution.
Leaving London after the
British wanted to charge him
for teaching him their
ineffective oral methods,
which they maintained were secret.
He went to Saint-Jacques
and took back to the States
with him a prominent
teacher named Laurant Clerc.
Clerc and Gallaudet brought
Bébian's teaching with him
to the United States,
with which they formed
the Deaf core of American teachers.
English immigrants had given us our spoken
and written language, but
the French and the person
of Laurent Clerc enriched
American Sign Language
with French Sign and used a
new combined language, ASL,
to teach the American
Deaf the written language
of France's rival across the channel.
By the 1850's, some
250 of the 550 teachers
and administrators in the
burgeoning national network
of schools were themselves Deaf.
By the 1860's, there was
26 schools and sign was
the language of instruction of all.
But for a variety of reasons,
the champions of speech
teaching would never let go.
Bébian's Deaf pupil, Ferdinand Berthier,
the greatest Deaf teacher of the Deaf
and Deaf leader of the 19th century
was well aware of it.
He did a lot to try to stop it.
One of the most beautiful
things he did, I think,
was to organize annual Deaf
banquets that were held
all around Paris between
1832 and 1869 or so.
He invited the greats to come
(speaking in foreign language)
and many others.
Like today, he had
children of Deaf parents
who were hearing do the interpreting
so that everybody could
understand everybody else
just as we are doing today.
Berthier was also a poet.
I'll quote this poem because I love it.
It's much better than
my English translation
but here goes.
As background, the Phoenician alphabet,
about 1000 B.C. is the source
of virtually all modern alphabets.
Berthier himself referred to this point
in his own poem pronouncing
in Sign Language
and interpreted by another
at one of these banquets.
Here it is: we do not speak, it is true,
but still, do you think us
unable to express ourselves
as well with our eyes, our
hands, our smiles, our lips?
Our most beautiful discourse
is at the tips of our fingers
and our language is
rich in secret beauties
that you who speak will never know.
Have we not, have we not,
our own art of Phoenecian
to paint the words that
speak into our eyes?
Your arts and sciences, safe or sound,
are they not open to our ardent eyes?
Show us the heavens,
ambitious airs of Acarus
that I cannot ascend with you.
But as I say, Berthier was well aware
of the forces against him.
He warned his colleagues
and students alike
that if they didn't
fight for their education
in their own language,
they would lose everything.
After Bébian, the 19th
century Oralist movement
deliberately set out to
destroy the languages
and educational institutions of the Deaf.
In fact, the movement all but ruined
the extraordinary accomplishments
of the great European
and American teachers of the
earlier part of the century.
The Oralists were lead
by Alexander Graham Bell
and by hearing teachers of the Deaf
and others in Europe
and the United States.
At the 1880 Congress of Milan,
as many of us here know,
a gathering of hearing educators
went with little knowledge
of the signed languages.
The assembly proudly
proclaimed the incontestable
superiority of speech
over sign and resolved
that Deaf students
should be taught only by
the pure oral method.
Before long, throughout
Europe, speech became
virtually the sole method of teaching.
By requiring Deaf students
to hear or lip read
and to speak, impossible tasks.
Virtually impossible tasks.
Milan made so faculty...
Milan made the sole
faculty the students lacked
the instrument of their instruction.
What was the motive of the Oralists?
Why insist on teaching a
child words he couldn't speak
and staring at lips he
couldn't understand?
For some, notably the
oral teachers, the motive
was the desire to keep their jobs.
As to Bell, he conceded that Sign Language
was the quickest method
of reaching the mind
of a Deaf child, but it was
not the mind of a Deaf child
that interested Bell.
Quote: the production of a defective race
of signing human beings,
he wrote, would be
a great calamity to the world.
If they were deprived of
their language of signs,
the Deaf would be unable
to understand not only
the hearing but each other.
They would marry less,
have fewer children,
and their number would diminish.
Even Bell's prejudice ideas about eugenics
were without foundation
for as mentioned earlier
about 95% of children
born Deaf then and today
are born of hearing parents.
Bell and his allies were
extraordinarily successful.
In 1867, American Sign
Language had been the median
of instruction in all
educational institutions
for the Deaf.
By 1927, it was used in virtually none.
Deaf students were graduating
from Oralist schools
in Europe and America as
functional illiterates
in the written languages
of their native countries.
Gallaudet College was
discouraging its students
from becoming teachers.
In France, the country of
Bébian, as recently as 2015
a prominent ear surgeon
wrote in Le Figaro,
that quote: speech is the only language
the brain can comprehend, unquote.
Finally, some brighter sides.
The eminent linguist, Noam
Chomsky, giving a lecture
in Chicago in 1965,
mistakenly, that's so rare
that Chomsky makes a
mistake, defined language
as a specific sound to
meaning correspondence.
When asked where this
left the sign languages
of the Deaf, Chomsky
revised his definition
on the spot calling
language a specific signal
to meaning correspondence.
The distinction was
important for it was offered
at a time when William
Stokoe and his colleagues
at Gallaudet University
were rediscovering,
they were rediscovering,
what had been known in France
and America in the early 19th century.
Much of what Stokoe wrote
about in linguistics
was really taken from
Bébian's own writings.
Stokoe gave him credit, it
was very inconspicuous credit,
but he did give Bébian credit.
So these ideas that are coming up today,
they're not new ideas.
These were ideas that were developed
in the early 19th century
and were suppressed
with the money of Bell
and the United States,
with the Perriere's in
Europe, with the help of
the Oralist teachers
and the Oralist movement
and they basically smothered what we knew
so much so that when
people rediscovered it
in the 20th century, they
thought they were discovering
something new and they weren't.
Chomsky's work and the work
of Stokoe and his successors
were of exceptional significance.
This was not so...
This was so not simply
because the hearing world
had forgotten what it
had known by the 1820's,
but because of the calamitous success
as I just said, and I'm repeating myself,
of the Oralist movement.
Have the thoughts and work of
Chomsky, Stokoe, and others
now helped to overcome the
educational plight of the Deaf?
They've unquestionably
led to a renaissance
of linguistic and educational
interest in sign languages,
giving new life, including
now our academic life
here at Yale, to the
seminal work of Bébian.
It is now broadly understood
that Chomsky's language faculty
operates with equal facility,
whether stimulated by
language heard by the ears of the hearing
or beheld by the eyes of the Deaf.
The primitive notions of
the Deaf and their language
espoused at Milan and promoted by Bell
are now rather thoroughly discredited
but the educational problems
of the Deaf persist today.
80% of newborn Deaf babies in the west
are being given cochlear implants.
The implants are devices,
as most of us know,
that produce hearing bypassing the ear
and delivering electronic
signals directly to
the auditory nerve.
The benefits of cochlear
implants are measured today
in a laboratory setting
and alas, appear to fall
far short outside that setting.
Thus, the real world
of daily communication
is still a struggle despite the device.
Notably, for children, who are born Deaf.
Language can be said to give all of us,
whether Deaf or hearing,
our modern soul in the age
of science and to underpin
our rights as individuals.
Whether that soul can best
be expressed and understood
and can best understand
the world around it
in its natural language,
or with cochlear implants,
or perhaps both, is the
heart and soul of the matter.
Is a smaller, fully
communicative world preferable
to a larger, poorly communicative one?
Is there a both worlds alternative?
Are the implants a paradigmatic change
or are they an extension
of the dramatic course
of 19th and 20th century Deaf
history and of earlier times?
There are a variety of views
on these hotly debated questions.
My own views are shaped
both by my own research,
by careful study of
published test results,
and naturally enough, by
my intimate acquaintance
with the history.
I propose no answers here,
but whatever the answers
it is critically important that we ensure
that these children going Deaf be given
the opportunity to learn
as soon as possible in life
what is their own, their
first, their natural language
and advocation of the soul itself.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you very much.
We now have some time for questions.
I suggest that we turn
your question period
into the question period for everyone.
So please feel free to ask questions
for our last speaker but also
for the other two panelists.
Okay.
We have two microphones
that will run up and down
the aisles to receive your questions.
Okay, see, we have a question here.
- [Audience Member] Hi, thank
you all for speaking today.
It was great.
Anyone can answer this but
it's a question regarding
the language acquisition.
- Be a little louder.
- [Audience Member] Oh,
it's a question regarding
the language acquisition.
I was wondering like we're
talking about in class
most if not all users
of sign are bilingual.
They have their language of sign and also
their written language
because Sign Language
doesn't have a written form.
So how are the acquisition
processes for these different?
Can you guys speak to your
personal experiences with this?
Because there's an understanding
of an inborn filter
for language, but does it work differently
for sign versus writing?
- [Woman] So I think the question is:
is the acquisition
process in Sign Language
different from the language
acquisition process
in spoken languages?
- [Audience Member] No,
for when you're learning
how to write the written language.
Because there's a written English language
versus a Sign Language.
Most users of sign are
bilingual in that sense.
So is a language acquisition
process for that different
and how does that work?
- [Interpreter] I can
speak a little bit to that.
I don't specialize in
literacy of Deaf children
but I do know a little bit
about the research that exists.
There are studies, a
great deal of studies,
looking at that.
There are, we know, Deaf
students who are very successful
in terms of literacy skills.
The question is how do they
become such good readers?
And how do they become
literate in a written language
that does not apply to their
Sign Language abilities?
It's entirely separate.
Because the written
language does not track
with the Sign Language that they use.
Let me just back up for just a minute.
For hearing children,
learning a spoken language
tracks with the written
language that they also learn.
There's much research that
shows phonological knowledge
of language really boosts
the ability to learn
to read and write.
So a lot of literacy instruction
has to do with phonology
and how that plays into
learning to read and write.
That phonology does not
map of the written language
does not map onto a Sign
Language used by Deaf students.
Research today is looking
at how Deaf students
may capitalize on the phonology
of their Sign Language
to assist in the process,
or support the process,
of learning to read and write.
Not all of the literacy
applies to Deaf children
in this area but there are
some findings that we can apply
to the situation in Deaf education.
So there's some evidence
that the morphology
of sign languages in having
phonology a foundation
in one language can be used
to enhance the language
learning process in literacy
of a second language.
- [Interpreter] I'd like to add one thing
to what Amber said.
So every child, regardless
of if they're learning
a spoken language or a Sign
Language has to be taught
how to read and write.
The writing systems aren't universal,
they're a cultural invention.
So it's always the case
that the process of learning
how to read and write is different
from language acquisition.
So the question is how is it
different for Sign Language
and visual language users,
versus spoken language users?
Because there's not a one-to-one mapping
in phonological firm and
that's the research question.
That we have not yet...
Well, we're still looking at now.
It's a current area of research.
- As to syntax, Bébian
made a wonderful point
in teaching kids that he
would first go through
the notion of a sentence.
This table, I strike.
I think in those days, I don't
know whether it's the case
now but the sentence would often begin
with the object.
So a signing student
would be signed by Bébian
this table, I strike.
He'd make sure the student got the idea
and then having been through the exercise
of teaching the child words and sentences
he would say well, when you write it down
you don't write this table, I strike.
You write I strike this table.
This is the way these
crazy hearing people do it.
(audience laughing)
He was quite good I
think at getting syntax
and grammar through to those kids.
- There's a question next to you.
- [Audience Member] A
friend of mine online
was upset with the
cochlear marketing where
children were not supposed
to be taught sign.
She herself was Deaf and she
was very offended with this
and I can certainly understand
her attitude towards genocide.
- [Woman] Towards, what did you say?
- [Audience Member] Genocide,
that's where you discriminate
an entire cultures.
That's what the cochlear people early on
were trying to do.
It's a natural, very typical,
natural asinine sort of thing people do.
They wanted to help people so of course
they had to exterminate
other efforts to help.
But looking into this,
it looks to me as though
baby sign is very beneficial
to the intellectual
and spiritual development
of small children
at a very important age of development.
A child who can express
himself at the age of one
is going to be developing
rhetorical abilities
an entire year before most
children can make noises
come out of their faces.
But now, this evening,
I understand baby sign
could be significant towards the training
of future engineers because
of the spatial aspect.
I say that very seriously.
A moment ago we were talking
about the inadequacies
of written language to
which I would respond
that there is also a subject of drafting
which could expend written language,
could be seen as
expanding written language
in the direction of spatial orientation.
So it seems to me that baby sign
is a very important subject.
Sign Language should not be confined
to special education or
of linguistic rarities
but should be learned by every parent.
Beyond that, I would like to know
how do I say Nicaragua?
That seems to be very
important this evening.
Nicaragua.
- How do you say what?
- Nicaragua.
- [Woman] Oh, Nicaragua.
Thank you for, yeah.
I guess it was a simple question
how do you say Nicaragua
and a longer question
about the importance of signs.
- [Interpreter] If you're
asking a specific question
about baby sign, I can't answer that
without first saying that
we can't talk about baby
signs for hearing children,
unless we also are
talking about education,
teaching Sign Language to Deaf children.
So I would say issues about
teaching hearing infants
to sign, okay.
That's an individual
decision for parents to make
but we can't talk about that first.
I think first we need to address the fact
that Deaf children need to
have equal opportunities.
That's where the focus needs to be first.
(audience laughing)
(mumbling)
This is the sign for Nicaragua.
Nicaragua.
In NSL.
(woman laughing)
- [Audience Member] I have a question for
particularly for Dr. Martin and colleagues
about the relationship between
the origins of language
and special works.
So one of the interesting things
in the archeological record
is that with a stone tool
traditions we see stone tools
from a couple of million years
ago and they're unchanged,
unchanged, unchanged, and
then get bifacial blades
the closer we get,
symmetrical stone flakes,
and then they stay unchanged,
unchanged, unchanged
and so on for another half a million years
and then we see a stone
tool specialization,
we see different shapes
of tools and so on.
So of course the production
of the bifacial blades,
the ones with the chips on either side,
requires being able to manipulate tools
and think about symmetry at the same time.
So I'm wondering if you see
that as a potential clue
to language development or
whether it's something like
the later proliferation of stone tools
and the variation and so on
which might be more indicative.
Is there any thoughts
you have on this matter
would be great?
- [Interpreter] Honestly,
I'm not sure exactly
what you're asking.
You're talking about
comparing the development
of those two things over
time in the emergence
of a language and how
spatial ideas like symmetry
and things like that.
How they influence and shape language,
is that what you're addressing?
- [Audience Member] It's
more the question related
to Dr. Kocab's point about
tracing language origins
and I guess cultural evolution
and biological evolution of language.
So we see these I guess evidence.
We see pieces of evidence
for cultural development
over millions of years but
yet the work on Nicaragua
and Sign Language suggests
that language development
for these kids is very quick within, what?
Two generations or three generations.
So I'm wondering what lessons
we can learn about reading
that contemporary situations
back into the remote past?
Yeah, that's kind of
how I feel about it too.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman] A difficult question, yeah.
- [Interpreter] I have some thoughts.
I'm not sure though if my thoughts though
will actually answer your question.
But would you like to take
a shot at that, Annemarie?
Something that comes to mind for me is
and I'm not sure if this is
exactly what you're asking.
Part of what Dr. Kocab talked about
in terms of cognitive tools
and resources that we have,
those may have appeared long, long ago
and those might be things
that we can take advantage of
to create language.
So the languages that we create must...
Those cognitive resources must be in place
for that to occur.
So the emergence of spatial language
and how it emerges, for example,
we see that for
people learning Sign Language,
well for all people, hearing or Deaf,
there are strengths and weaknesses
in terms of mental rotation capabilities.
What some of us are good
at, strength that we bring
to the table, come into play when we think
about human beings.
For those who talk about other things,
have other strengths and weaknesses,
there may be something
about the language itself
that uses certain skills to incorporate
into the development of the
language in the first place
so that the kind of thing
you might be talking about
is where long, long ago
historically perhaps
a cognitive ability emerged at some point
in the history of human
development and then there comes
a time where language is needed
to capitalize on something
to be able to do something
and then that feeds back
into the development of
the language as a cycle.
That's the type of thing
I'm thinking about.
I'm not sure if it addresses
what you're interested
in knowing about but
those are my thoughts.
- [Interpreter] I'm
also not completely sure
what the question was.
Well, so you said that tools
started out as one thing
and then at some point there
was a point where they became
widespread and specialized
and you're asking
if that parallels what we're
seeing in language emergence?
Was that the question you were asking
or are you talking
about Chomsky's proposal
for a single mutation
changes that allows for
our language faculty?
- [Audience Member] Yes,
so I guess the question...
I guess not exactly I guess
is the answer to that.
We have in the biological
versus the cultural ideas
about evolution of language.
There's this gradualist
idea that we build up
cultural scaffolding from
communications systems
which non-linguistic like
or part linguistic like
or something like that.
But we also have this
biological capacity for language
which is presumably relatively abrupt
if it's a single gene mutation.
It's the time it takes
for that to percolate
through a population
which could be anything...
- [Interpreter] Interpreters are actually
having trouble hearing you.
Your mic keeps dropping out it seems
so they're having difficulty
understanding the question
that you're asking and then
can't interpret it correctly.
- [Audience Member] Oh,
okay; yeah, I'm sorry.
Is that better if I hold
it a bit closer, okay?
Also maybe my accent.
I have an Australian
accent and also a cold.
It's a complicated topic as well.
I guess we have this biological abruptness
versus cultural gradualism
and some interplay of the
two and I think, Dr. Kocab,
you have made that very clear in your talk
to start the afternoon.
But we also have this work
in the cultural evolution literature
and the cognitive evolution literature
on these spatial manipulation...
Evolution of spatial manipulation,
evolution of stone tools,
and the combination
of the learning of how to make stone tools
and the cognitive capacity for just doing
the manipulation to make the
chips that we need to make
in the first place.
So just doing the
manipulation of the stone
to make the tools.
It was just dragging to me
that your two talks together
brought up many of these
points that come to debates
in this literature.
Yeah, so I was interested
in discussing that further.
But I agree it's a very complex topic
and if we had answers
here, we could all go home.
- [Woman] I think we have
time for one more question.
- [Audience Member] Mr.
Shea, in your striking book
the Language of Light, one
of the more striking aspects
of the story of Deaf
education to me, anyway,
was the role of Helen
Keller in that story.
You wanna tell a little bit about that?
- The answer would be a long one
but I'll try to make it short.
Helen Keller was remarkable.
She was Deaf and Blind
from the age of about seven
and she got all the way through Radcliffe
but there is disappointing
evidence in the history
that at a young age, the work
that was presented as her own
was in fact plagiarized by
Anne Sullivan from a book.
It was a great crisis in Helen's life.
The head of the Perkins
School in Boston disowned her
in fact and she ultimately
recovered from that.
Many people jumped to her defense.
She was only a child, of course,
but there is some thought
that much of her writing in later life
may have been written
in large part by others.
Whether it was or not, she was brilliant.
She did get through Radcliffe
and accomplished a lot.
But one of the problems
I think Helen always had,
she never learned how
to speak well audibly.
She never learned how to read lips
whether read lips by touch.
But Alexander Graham Bell used
her as a kind of adversement
for Oralist teaching and
his favorite phrase well
if Blind and Deaf Helen
Keller can speak and read lips
and learn so much then why can't the Deaf
or not Blind accomplish that?
But lots of what he said
about Helen was false.
It also turns out in history
that when Helen was very young
she had a well developed
system of home signs
which could have been
with the proper teachers
or somebody like Bébian and his successors
turned her into an even more
remarkable woman, a genius,
than she was without
the ability to practice
her own native language.
Those who are interested,
there's a full chapter
on Helen in the Language
of Light and you all
may find it interesting.
Thank you.
- Okay, sure.
There's one more question there.
- [Audience Member] All right, thank you.
I have a question.
A lot of hearing people,
especially hearing parents
now, are finding, you know,
the advantages of using
Sign Language with infants
right away after birth
because the brain is just
going right from the
beginning a child is born
and they're saying the
importance of making connection
to the things that are in the world
and it's just so helpful for a child
just on the ratio of knowledge.
My question is...
I've seen children here that
never had a basic language
like for instance a child
that might be in school
who really doesn't know
Sign Language, who's Deaf,
doesn't really understand
English even though
they're trying to teach that child English
because at home the family
is speaking Spanish.
So it seems like if you're missing
your fundamental language,
a foundational language,
you're really at a disadvantage.
Also, with us, you know,
with hearing parents
we're always talking to
our child so right away,
you know, it's putting on
the jacket, the booties.
This is milk.
You know, we're constantly
making a connection to things
for them to be able to,
you know, gain knowledge
of their environment.
I was just curious when
you were in Nicaragua,
did you find any Deaf
parents with Deaf children,
or did you find families
that had many Deaf members
to be able to see how they communicated
and if that communication
was so much better
because their children
were getting right away
connections to the environment rather than
three years of delayed
nothing, no language,
no fundamental language
until they got into school.
Did you find any families like that
or is that something
you'd be interested in?
Thank you.
- [Interpreter] There
are a few individuals
who have Deaf relatives,
Deaf aunts, and so forth.
Yes, their language tends to be
on par with what we would see
in a typically developing situation.
Absolutely having a rich environment
has a positive impact on
their language development.
One thing I want to make
sure that I emphasize,
so often hearing parents
who have a Deaf child
are afraid, how will I learn
Sign Language well enough?
I can't possibly do that.
That's not my language.
That fear sometimes drives them,
and there are a multitude
of other reasons as well,
drive them to using spoken English.
I didn't highlight this
in my talk but a lot
of what we know is that children
are prodigious language learners
and they often will surpass their input.
Really, the message that
we want to send to parents
is that anything helps.
Learning sign with your kid helps
their language development,
that's been shown.
So don't underestimate what the kid has
and what they can do.
- [Interpreter] Right.
And Deaf families in
Nicaragua are quite rare.
I actually don't know
anyone whose taken a look
at counting that.
We know of a few but there aren't many.
I feel like there's more
here in the United States,
but I could be wrong.
I don't think there's
ever been a count done.
In Nicaragua, I certainly
don't know of many
but a couple, yes.
- [Woman] Okay, last question.
- [Audience Member] I
already spoke so I'm happy
to give up the mic to somebody who hasn't.
- [Woman] Why don't you
speak so the interpreters
can hear you?
- [Audience Member] Okay, I'll just talk.
So I have a couple questions.
My first one being as two
highly successful Deaf women,
how do you go about facing
prejudice in the work place?
I mean, that's just
really fascinating to me.
I'm a coder and so I
kind of have experience
seeing that prejudice.
I'm just wondering...
I mean, I'm so, so happy
that you guys are here.
I don't know.
I'm just interested in that.
How do you give advice
about counteracting that
prejudice and thinks like that?
Sorry, that's so much.
(audience laughing)
- [Interpreter] Wow.
Yes, it's okay in many
different ways, all the time.
- [Audience Member] I'm so sorry.
- [Interpreter] Maybe it will be helpful
if you are curious about
if we're currently facing
that prejudice as adults
or when we were younger
because my answer would be
different in those two contexts.
- [Audience Members] You
guys are both working at
high ranking institutions.
Do you feel like you
still experience that?
Okay.
Sorry, that's a bad question.
- [Interpreter] It's fine.
- [Interpreter] Okay, yes, I
can say a couple of things.
Yes, I do experience things like that.
Also, I have created a space for myself
at my current place of employment
where I make it work for me.
I make it that way
intentionally for myself.
And also I have support from colleagues
in my workplace.
So to be honest, I think
I have a pretty good place
of employment where my
colleagues are supportive of me
and my work and they listen
to what I have to say
about what I need.
They basically allow me
to design the system there
that I want, that works for me.
I think it's partly because,
well, quite honestly
I don't know why that is.
I do feel that there are
just good people there.
- [Interpreter] Just, I'll
briefly add one thing.
This goes back to the intro of this panel.
I'm lucky that I'm in
the field that I'm in
that appreciates the
importance of Sign Language,
not only socially but on an intellectual
and academic level.
I'm also lucky because my institution
has a lot of resources to
support me in that work
but being in an environment where people
really are appreciative of
the study of Sign Language
like you all are, that helps a lot.
That's why I really
thank you all for hosting
this wonderful event.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
(whimsical music)